So following the theophany
at the burning Bush,
Moses returns to Egypt and he initiate
what will become ultimately a battle of
wills between Pharaoh and God.
And the story in exodus has high
drama and lots of a folkloric elements
including this contest between Moses and
Aaron on the one hand and the magicians
of Egypt.
On the other hand,
and this kind of contest is a very
common literary device. It's a kind of,
you know,
our boys are better than your boys device.
The Egyptian magicians who are initially
able to mimic some of the plagues that
are brought on by God.
They are quickly bested and uh,
y'all always defeat of the magicians is
tantamount to the defeat of the gods of
Egypt. There are 10 plagues.
These include a bloody pulp,
a pollution of the Nile,
swarms of frogs, lice,
insects,
affliction of livestock,
boils that afflict humans and animals,
lightning and hail locusts,
total darkness.
And all of this climax is in the death
of the firstborn males of Egypt in one
night. And source critics looking
at this material discern, um,
numerous diverse sources that
are interwoven throughout.
And these sources preserve different
traditions on the number and the nature of
the plagues as well as the principal
actors in the drama, God, Moses, Aaron,
so according to the
source critical analysis,
no source contains 10 plagues and Jay
has eight and he has three and p has five
and some of them are the same as one
another and some of them are different and
so on. Some of them are unique
to one source, some are not,
but ultimately the claim is that these
have all been merged and have left us.
Then with an overall total of 10 this
may in fact be true. Nevertheless,
as much as we like to engage sometimes
in this kind of analysis about the
sources that have gone into
the composition of the text,
it's also always important to keep your
eye on the final form of the Texas.
We've received it literary analysis that
is sensitive to the larger contours of
the account will reveal the
artistic hand of the final editor.
I've charted this at the
top of the board here.
Some scholars have noticed
that the plagues are organized
in three sets of three
and there are literary links that connect
them and make it clear that these are
three sets of three followed by the
climactic 10th plague. And again,
three and 10 are ideal
numbers in our biblical texts.
Each set of three shares,
certain structural and literary features.
So in each set, the first and
second plague our four warrants.
That's what the FW is on the side, whereas
the third plague is not. So a warning,
a warning, and then a third
plague, a warning, a warning,
and then a third plague,
a warning, a warning, and
then a third play in each set.
The first plague is accompanied by a
notation of the time in the morning.
It's also introduced by
God's speech and God says,
present yourself before Pharaoh.
And to do this in the morning,
so each of the first plagues in the
sets of three is introduced this way.
And the second plague in each set of
three is introduced with the divine
instruction.
Go to Pharaoh.
The third plague in each set has
no forewarning and no introduction.
So this sort of structural repetition
creates a crescendo that leads then to the
final and most devastating plague,
which is the slaughter of
the Egyptian firstborn sons.
The slaughter may be understood as
measure for measure punishment for the
Egyptians earlier killing
of Hebrew infants in the um,
but it's represented in the biblical
text as retaliation for Egypt's treatment
of Israel. And Israel is referred to
as the first born son if you halfway.
So in exodus four verse 22,
now he tells Moses to say to Pharaoh,
thus says the Lord, Israel is my
firstborn son. I have said to you,
let my son go that he may worship me,
yet you refuse to let him go.
Now I will slay your firstborn son.
So it's seen as retaliation.
In this last plague,
God or his angel of death passes over
Egypt at midnight slaying every Egyptian
firstborn male Moses orders each
Israelite to perform a ritual action,
and this action will protect
them from the slaughter.
And the ritual consists of two parts.
Each family is told to sacrifice a lamb.
The lamb will then be eaten as a family
meal and it's blood will be smeared on
the doorposts, um, to mark the house.
So the angel of death knows to pass over
that house and the pen works in Hebrew
as well as an English, which
is kind of handy. In addition,
each family is to eat unleavened bread.
So according to exodus,
this Passover ritual was established on
Israel's last night of slavery while the
angel of death passed over the
dwellings that were marked with blood.
The story of tests to a phenomenon
that's long been observed by biblical
commentators and scholars,
and that is the Israelite
historic preservation of
preexisting ritual practices.
In other words,
what we probably have here are two
older separate springtime rituals.
One would be characteristic
of semi nomadic pastoralists,
the sacrifice of the first land born
in the spring to the deity in order to
procure a favor and
continued blessing on the,
the flux for the spring.
The other would be characteristic
of agriculturalists.
It would be an offering of the very first
barley that would be harvested in the
spring. It would be quickly ground into
flour and used before it even has time to
ferment,
to quickly offer something to the dd
again to procure favor for the rest of the
crop.
It's supposed by many that Israel was
formed in from the merger or the merging
of diverse groups including
farmers and in Canaan.
The rituals of these older
groups were then linked,
retained and then linked to the story
of the Enslavement and liberation of the
Hebrews.
So you have older nature festivals and
observances that have been historicized.
They're associated now with events in
the life of the new nation rather than
being grounded in the cycles of nature.
This may in fact be then part of the
process of differentiation from the
practices of Israel's neighbors who would
have celebrated the springtime rituals.
So now the blood of the sacrificial lamb
is said to have protected the Hebrews
from the angel of death and the
bread now is said to have been eaten,
consumed in unleavened form because the
Hebrews left Egypt in in such a hurry.
They had no time to allow the
dough to rise historic cessation.
And we'll see the sister organization of
rituals, um, recurring again and again.
Now following the last plague,
pharaoh finally allows the Israelites to
go into the desert to worship their god,
but he quickly changes his mind and he
sends his infantry and his chariots in
hot pursuit of the Israelites.
And they soon find themselves trapped
between the Egyptians and something
referred to as yum sufe
meaning read c it doesn't, uh,
it isn't the Red Sea.
That's a mistranslation that
occurred very, very early on.
So it's led to the notion that they were
at the Gulf of Aqaba or somewhere near
the actual big, big ocean water. Um,
and some of the Israelites despair
and they want to, um, surrender.
Was it for want of graves in Egypt that
you brought us to die in the wilderness?
What have, what have you done
to us taking us out of Egypt?
Is this not the very thing we told
you in Egypt saying, let us be,
we will serve the Egyptians
for it's better for us to
serve the Egyptians and to
die in the wilderness. But Moses rallies
them. And then in the moment of crisis,
God intervenes on Israel's behalf.
And once again,
SARS critics see in the account of the
parting of the Reed Sea in exodus 14 and
15,
three different versions of the events
of the event that have been interwoven.
I have to stress though that scholars
differ very much on where the seams and
the tech star, what parts of the
story belonged to j or e or p.
So you'll read very, very different
accounts. There's some, some consensus,
but that a lot of disagreement.
One thing that most people do in fact
agree on is that the oldest account of the
event is a poetic fragment that's
found in Exodus 15 verses one to 12 in
particular. Um, this is often
referred to as the song of the sea.
And here the image is one of thinking
and drowning in the Sea of reeds.
You have a wind that
blasts from God's nostrils,
the water's stand straight like a wall.
And at a second blast,
the sea then covers the Egyptians and
they sink like a stone in the majestic
waters.
The him doesn't anywhere refer to
people crossing over on dry land.
It seems to depict a storm at sea
almost as if the Egyptians are in boats.
And a bid when makes a giant wave and
another one that makes it crashed down on
them. So they're swamped
by these roiling waters.
But the name yum soup read see implies a
more marsh like setting rather than the
open sea. Uh, John Collins, who's a
professor here at the divinity school.
Now he points out that this image,
particularly in poetic passages,
this image of sinking in deep waters,
um,
it occurs often in Hebrew poetry.
It occurs particularly in the book of
Psalms and where it's a metaphor for
distress.
And Psalm 69 the psalmist asks God to
save him for waters have come up to my
neck, I think in deep Meyer
where there is no foothold.
I have come into deep waters and floods
sweeps over me. But a few verses later,
it's clear that the poet
isn't really drowning.
This is a metaphor for his difficult
situation more in number than the hairs of
my head are those who hate
me without cause. Many are
those who would destroy me,
My enemies who accused me falsely.
So Collins suggests that the poem in
Exodus 15 is celebrating and preserving a
historical memory of an escape from or
defeat of Pharaoh and that the drowning
image is used metaphorically as it is
elsewhere in Hebrew poetry to describe the
Egyptians humiliation and defeat.
Later writers take this poetic image
and fill out the illusion to drowning in
this ancient song and compose the pros
accounts in exodus 14 in which the
metaphor is literalized.
According to these pros accounts.
Now Pharaoh's army was
literally drowned in water,
but even in the pros
accounts. Um, in exodus 14,
we can see a composite of two intertwined
versions in the material that's
usually associated with p.
Moses is depicted as stretching out
his staff first to divide the waters,
which stand like a wall so that the
Israelites can cross over on dry land.
And then he holds out his staff to
bring the waters crashing down on the
Egyptians.
But according to one little section,
this is just a verses 24 and 25 in
exodus 14 some attribute this to Jay,
it seems that the Egyptians were
stymied by their own chariots.
The image we get there is that the
Israelites are sort of working their way
through the marsh on
foot and the Egyptians,
chariot wheels can't make
it through the marsh.
They get stuck in the mud and this
forces them to give up the chase.
So the final narrative that emerges
from this long process of transmission,
perhaps a core image of, of escape
on foot where chariots are bogged.
Um,
a poem that describes the defeat in,
in metaphorical terms using a drowning
and sinking image and then pros
elaboration on these previous traditions
that that have had very dramatic
element of the sea being parted
and crashing down on the Egyptians.
A long process of
transmission interweaving.
Literary embellishment has gone into the
creation of this account and exodus 14
and 15 but the story as it stands,
reiterate a motif that we've seen before
that of the threatened destruction of
God's creation or God's people by chaotic
waters and of divine salvation from
that threat. What's interesting
about the song of the sea,
this poetic fragment and Exodus 15 is
that here the Hebrews adopt the language
of Canaanite Myth and
apply it to your pathway.
If you still have that sheet that was
handed out before listing different
epithets for bowel and listing
epithets for Yaffe way,
it would be handy to have that or
to take a look at it later. Again,
because of the description of
yeah way is that of a storm. God.
In Exodus 15 he heaps up the waters with
a blast of wind like a storm at sea,
and this is reminiscent of
the Canaanites Storm. God Bow,
as you see on your handout by
Allah said to ride on the clouds.
He's a storm God and he's accompanied
by wind and rain at the beginning of the
rainy season.
But I'll opens a slit or makes a slit
in the clouds and funders and shakes the
earth. In one important legend that
we have from the Canaanite texts,
Ugaritic texts,
he defeats an adversary who's
known as prince see or judge river.
And after he vanquishes this watery foe,
he is a claimed the king of
the gods and the king of men.
And he is housed in a home,
not a tent as El was,
l was housed in a tent, but now this
bile is housed in a permanent structure,
a home that is on top of a mountain
and has built a cedar. Now,
ancient Hebrew descriptions of,
yeah,
white employed Barry's similar language
in the poetic passage here in Exodus 15
but also in other poetic passages.
So for example,
Psalm Psalm 68 verse five
extol him who rides the clouds.
The Lord is his name. Yeah, he is his
name. So extol him who rides the clouds.
Y'All way is his name as if
to say not val. So yeah, wait,
is described like bow
as riding on the clouds.
Psalm 29 also employs
the language of a storm.
Got The voice of the
Lord is over the waters.
The God of Glory thunders the
Lord over the mighty waters.
Some scholars think this actually was
originally a psalm about bow that was
simply adopted and referred to Yak way.
Images of God engaged in a battle with
some kind of watery fo also appear in the
psalms.
Psalm 74 Oh God,
my king from of old who brings
deliverance throughout the land.
It was you who drove back the sea with
your mind who smashed the heads of the
monsters in the waters and so on.
Judges five is also another ancient song
fragment verses four to five that uses
the same kind of imagery
imagery. Now, Michael Colgan,
who's a very important biblical scholar,
um, and an expert in the Canaanite texts,
yoga Riddick materials,
he's made some intriguing observations
in connection with the biblical
representation of your way in terms
that are so reminiscent of the storm God
bow.
He notes that bow was the
key figure in a change,
a change in the religion of Canaan that
happens somewhere between 1500 and 1200
BCE.
And that is also the traditional time for
what we think of as the exodus and the
introduction of Ya'll wisdom
or the differentiation of yeah.
Wisdom at this time.
Somewhere in this period
there was a transfer of power
in the Canaanite Pantheon
so that um, the, from a transfer power
from the older gods to the younger gods,
the older got l the sky,
God was replaced by the younger storm,
God by aisle, and he was replaced
by virtue of his defeat of France.
See, or whoever this watery
pho is. So l is replaced by,
by aisle after a defeat of some watery
fo Kogan notes that at about the same
time,
there seems to have been a similar change
in many of the world's traditions or
as many of the traditions of the region.
If a younger storm,
God who usurps power from an older God
by virtue of a victory over a water God.
Remember Enuma Elish, which we read
at the very beginning of the semester,
you have the young storm
God Marduk who defeats Tmr,
the watery,
ferocious deep monster and does
so by blasting a wind into her.
And so establishes his claim to rule
instead of the Old Sky God honor,
honor in India,
the storm God,
Indra about this time assumes the place
of a previous God dials and in Greece,
Zeus who is associated with a storm,
right thunder lightening bolts
you think of in the hands of Zeus,
he replaces Kronos who had
been the head of the Pantheon.
And so here in exodus we find that just
as the nation of Israel is coming into
existence, just as the Israelites
are making the transition from, um,
a nomadic existence to a
more settled way of life,
ultimately in their own land,
there seems to be a collective memory
of a similar change in her religion,
like the storm. God's in the myths
of Israel's neighbors, Yahweh,
heaps up the waters with a blast of wind.
He wins a stunning victory.
He establishes himself as the god of
the Israelites in place of l who was
worshiped by Israel's
Patriarchs, remember, and like
the Canaanite God by Isle.
Yeah. Way as we will see, as
we continue to read the text,
he will eventually want a house for
himself, a top of a Mountain Mount Zion,
and it will be lined with Cedar.
There are of course,
important ways in which Israel,
his use of the storm God motif diverges
from that of other ancient near eastern
stories.
The most important is that yaquis battle
is a historic battle rather than a
mythic battle,
right?
The Sea is not y'all always opponent,
right, nor is he always enemy.
Another God, Yahweh. He is doing
battle here with a human fo,
the Egyptian Pharaoh and his army.
The sea is a weapon deployed. It's a,
it's a weapon in the divine arsenal
and it's deployed on behalf of Israel.
But again,
yeah.
Whitey is depicted by the biblical
writer as transcending nature,
using forces of nature
for a historical purpose,
acting in history to deliver his
people and create a new nation, Israel.
So just as in genesis one,
the universe is created when the wind
of God parts the prime evil waters.
So in exodus 14 and 15 a new nation is
created when the wind of God parts the
waters of the Reed Sea.
But to describe what was understood to
be a historic event, a onetime event,
not a recurring mythical event,
but a historic event.
The ancient Israelites employed language
and images drawn naturally from the
traditions and myths of their
broader cultural context.
Or I should say that word, the cultural
context in which they themselves existed,
while at the same time differentiating
themselves to some degree. Now,
as has long been noted,
the Exodus Event became the paradigm
of God's salvation of his people.
And when I say salvation,
I don't mean that in the later Christian
sense of personal salvation from sin.
That's a notion that's anachronistically
read back into the by built into the
Hebrew Bible.
It's not their salvation in the Hebrew
Bible does not refer to an individual's
deliverance from a sinful nature.
This is not a concept we
find in the Hebrew Bible.
It refers instead to the
concrete collective communal
salvation from national
suffering and impression,
particularly in the form of
foreign rule or enslavement.
When biblical writers speak of Galloway
as Israel's redeemer and Savior,
they are referring to,
yeah,
always physical deliverance of the nation
from the hands of her foes and we're
going to see this increasingly as
we move to the prophetic material.
So the exodus is a paradigm for salvation,
but it would be a mistake I think to
view the exodus as the climax of the
preceding narrative.
We've gotten to this point now and we
have this big dramatic scene at the Reed
Sea, but the physical redemption
of the Israelites is not,
in fact the end of our story.
It's a dramatic way station in a story
that's going to reach its climax in the
covenant that will be concluded at Sinai.
And as many sensitive readers
of the Bible have noted,
the road from Egypt leads not to the other
side of the Reed Sea, but onto Sinai.
God's redemption of the Israelites
is a redemption for a purpose,
a purpose that doesn't become clear
until we get to Sinai. For at Sinai,
the Israelites will become God's
people bound by a covenant.
And so the story continues.
In the third month after the exodus,
the Israelites arrive at the wilderness
of Sinai and they in camp at the
mountain where Moses was first
called by God, the text says,
the Covenant concluded at Sinai is
referred to as the Mosaic Covenant.
So this is now our third covenant
that we have encountered.
We will have one more coming.
Um,
and the mosaic covenant differs radically
from the Noaa hide and the Abrahamic
or patriarchal covenants that
we've already seen. Because here,
God makes no promises beyond being
the patron or protector of Israel.
And also in this covenant,
he sets terms that require obedience
to a variety of laws and commandments.
So the Mosaic Covenant
is neither unilateral.
This is now a bilateral covenant
mutual reciprocal obligations,
nor is it unconditional like the
other two. It is conditional,
so this is our first bilateral
conditional covenant.
If Israel doesn't fulfill her
obligations by obeying God's Torah,
his instructions,
and living in accordance with his
will as expressed in the laws and
instructions,
then God will not fulfill his obligation
of protection and blessing towards
Israel.
Now,
the biblical scholar Jon Levenson here
maintains that historical critical
scholarship has been unkind to biblical
Israel because of a pervasive bias
between the two main focus of
the religion of ancient Israel.
Those are the Torah or the law is it's,
it's an understood as the law,
not a great translation.
I prefer instruction,
but Tara taken to me in the law on
the one hand and temple on the other.
He says that on the one hand,
negative stereotypes rooted in Paul's
condemnation of mosaic law as a deadening
curse from which belief in
Jesus offers liberation.
That account colors, scholarly
accounts of the giving of the Torah.
On the other hand,
a Protestant distaste for priest
centered cultic ritual colors,
scholarly accounts of the temple and its
meaning for ancient Israelites so that
these biases are so much
embedded in our culture.
He says they permeate the work of
even secular scholars of the Bible,
so that a negative view of the law affects
interpretation of the book of Exodus.
Scholars tend to place great emphasis on
the deliverance from Egypt as the high
point and the exodus narrative rather
than the more natural literary climax,
which is the conclusion of the Covenant
at Mount Sinai and the delivery of the
Torah. So Levenson in
his book, Sinai and Zion,
he tries to correct this prejudice,
prejudicial treatment.
He says he seeks to give the two central
institutions of Torah on the one hand
in temple on the other a fair hearing.
So when his book Sinai and Zion
Levinson Explores these, um,
the two great,
when he calls the two great mountain
traditions that express these central
concepts,
the tradition of Mount Sinai,
that's where Israel received the Torah
and entered into this defining covenantal
relationship with God.
And then on the other hand,
the tradition of Mount Zion Zion will
be the future site of the nation's holy
temple in Jerusalem.
Mount Zion is in Jerusalem.
It's the Temple Mount today where
the, the, the mosque now is,
um, today, uh,
we'll consider Levinson's analysis of
the Sinai tradition as an entree into the
Israelite concept of the
Torah and the Covenant Bond,
its meaning and its implications.
So 11th and stresses the importance
of the Covenant formulary.
There are ancient near eastern parallels
to the Sinai covenant of the Bible,
especially Hittite treaties had tight
treaties that date to 1500 to 1200 or so,
also as Syrian treaties in
about the eighth century.
But they are in many ways continuous
continuous with what you find in the
Hittite treaties, treaties between
a [inaudible] and a vassal.
You remember we talked
about two types of treaties,
suzerainty treaties and parody treaties,
parody treaties between equals,
but suzerainty treaties are between a
Suzanne who has a position obviously of
power and authority and a vassal and
he details the following six elements,
which I hope you can all see and um,
especially in the Hittite treaties,
not all found in every treaty,
but they're often enough found that we
can speak of these six elements. First,
there is a preamble that's
found in everyone. This is
a rant, identifies himself.
Second of all,
there's generally an account
of the historical circumstances
that are leading to
the treaty,
so some kind of historical prologue.
Then we usually have some sort of set of
stipulations and requirements upon the
vassal.
Generally a force.
There's generally some arrangement either
for the publication of the treaty or
its deposition.
It's safekeeping and some sort of shrine.
There is generally a concluding
invocation of witnesses.
Usually the gods are invoked
as witnesses to a binding oath,
some kind of covenantal oath
that brings the cup, the,
the treaty into effect and it's
witnessed by God's. Lastly,
there will be very often a
list of blessings for the
party who obeys and curses
for the party that violates the pact.
And the curses are particularly
emphasized in the Assyrian treaties.
They are really fun reading.
So Levinson then identifies
these elements, uh,
many of these elements in the ways very
first speech to Moses and Moses and the
Israelites arrive at Sinai in Exodus
19 and God says the following,
a in x in verses three,
three B two eight,
the Lord called to him
from the mountain saying,
thus shall you say to the House of
Jacob and declare it to the children of
Israel, you have, sorry. You have
seen what I did to the Egyptians,
how I bore you on Eagle's
wings and brought you to me
now then if you will obey
me faithfully and keep my covenant,
you shall be my treasured possession among
all the peoples and did all the earth
is mine, but you shall be to me a
kingdom of priests and a holy nation.
These are the words that you shall
speak to the children of Israel.
Moses came and some of the elders of the
people and put before them all that the
Lord had commanded him and all the people
answered this one saying all that the
Lord has spoken,
we will do.
And Moses brought back the people's
words to the Lord. So 11 son who,
who draws actually on long standing work
by other scholars and earlier in the
19th century even,
um,
Levinson find several of the main elements
of the Hittite suzerainty treaties in
this speech. So verse four, you've
seen what I did to the Egyptians.
How I bore you on Eagle's Eagle's wings
is the historical prologue, right?
That's the reason that we're in the
situation we're in now and making this
covenant.
Verse five contains Gods stipulations.
It's a very general
conditional if you obey,
my law is basically keep my
covenant obeyed me faithfully.
That's the conditional that's going to
be filled out and articulated at great
length in the file in the following
chapters in the subsequent chapters.
But all of the laws they
have to obey or spelled out.
The second half of verse five
and six gives the reward.
God is conferring on the Israelites.
This elevated status of,
of royalty of priesthood. You'll be to be
a kingdom of priests and a holy nation.
And in verse eight,
the people solomnly undertake to
fulfill the terms of the covenant.
So we have at least three of the steps,
um,
that we find in the
Hittite treaty as well.
If we take a broader view of the full
biblical account of Israel's covenant with
God, all six elements can be
identified in the biblical narrative.
They're scattered throughout the text.
However,
we have the preamble and the historical
background to the covenant in Gods'
summary.
Introduction to the people in Exodus 20
I am Yahweh who brought you out of the
land of Egypt,
sums it all up.
Introduction who I am and why we are
historically connected. So this fact,
God's bringing Israel out of Egypt,
presumably establishes
God's claim to sovereignty.
The terms of the treaty are
then stipulated at great
length in the instructions
that are found in Exodus Chapter 23
Chapter 23 Moses reads the book of the
Covenant. It's called the scroll
of the Covenant. Publicly.
This is said in exodus 24
verse seven and Deuteronomy,
we read that it will be deposited
for safe keeping and a special arc.
The Israelites vow that they will obey.
Exodus 24 verse three also seven be
a covenant is then sealed by a formal
ritual. In this case it's a
sacrifice in exodus 24 verse eight.
In a monotheistic system,
you can't really call upon other
gods to be witnesses to the,
to the ceiling of the oath.
Um,
so we have heaven in earth
being invoked as witnesses.
Deuteronomy four verse 26.
Deuteronomy 30 verse 1931 verse 28,
Heaven and earth.
The idea of being perhaps the
inhabitants thereof should witness as for
blessings and curses.
We have a long list of each found in
Leviticus 26 and Deuteronomy 28 also
interesting reading and
some of these curses,
particularly the ones in Deuteronomy bear
a very striking resemblance to curses
in um,
an a theory and treaty that we have that
was found dates to about six 77 BCE.
The Assyrian King asked or hadn't.
And many of the courses are
really almost word for word.
So while no one passage contains all of
the elements of the Hittite treaty form,
um, there are enough of them scattered
around to suggest it as a model as well as
its later instantiation
in is in a Syrian culture.
So what's the meaning of this?
Why does it matter that Israel
understands its relationship with God and,
and uses the covenant as a vehicle for
expressing its relationship with God? Um,
the vehicle of the Suzerainty Treaty
Treaty Levinson according to 11 sin,
the use of a suzerainty treaty as the
model for Israel's relationship to
Callaway expresses several key ideas
that captures several key ideas.
First,
the historical prologue that's so central
to the scissor anti-treaty grounds the
obligations of Israel to halfway in
the history of his acts on her behalf.
And so it was granted
in historical moment.
We'll come back to this and what that
might mean about her perception of God.
Second, the historical prologue
bridges the gap between generations,
Israel's past and present and future
generations form a collective entity
Israel.
That collectively a sense to the covenant
and even today at Passover ceremonies
everywhere,
Jews are reminded to see
themselves reminded of the
obligation to see themselves
as if they personally came out of Egypt
and personally covenanted with God.
The historical prologue thirdly explains
why Israel accepts her place in the
Susan Vassal relationship.
Israel's acceptance of a relationship
with God doesn't stem from a mystical
introspection or
philosophical speculation.
Levenson says instead,
the Israelites are affirming
their identity and their
relationship with God by
telling a story,
a story whose moral can only
be that God is reliable.
Israel can rely on God just as
a vassal can rely on his Susan.
The goal is not Levenson says ultimately
the affirmation of God's suzerainty in
a purely verbal sense then right.
The point is not mere verbal.
A claim of God as Susan
Levinson points out,
that the affirmation of God's suzerainty
is rendered in the form of obedience to
commandments,
not mere verbal acclamation.
Observance of God's commandments
is as Levinson puts it,
the teleological end of history.
Why is that important?
Unless we recognize that the road from
Egypt leads an extra bleach to Sinai,
but the story of national liberation
issues in and as subordinate to is
ultimately subordinate to the obligation
to God's covenant stipulations and
observance of his laws.
Then we run the risk of doing what has
been done for some centuries now of
reading exodus.
That's first and foremost a story of a
miraculous delivery rather than the story
of a relationship which is expressed
through obligations to the observance of
specific laws,
commandments and instructions.
So the Souza and vassal model has
further implications. Other scholars,
Levinson and other scholars point many
of these out just as the ancient near
eastern suzerainty treaties specify that
vassals of a Susan are to treat other
vassals of the Susan well.
Um,
Israelites are bound to one another then
as vassals of the same Susan and are to
treat one another.
Well.
And so covenant in Israel becomes
the basis of social ethics, right?
It's the reason that God
gives instructions regarding
the treatment of one's
fellow Israelites, right? So the
Susan Vassal relationship grounds,
the social ethic within Israel also just
as a vassal cannot serve two Susan's
that's pretty explicit in all the treaties
you oh exclusive service two years
Susan.
So the covenant with God entails the
notion of Israel's exclusive service of
Yahweh.
The assertion is not that there is no
other God but that Israel will have no
other God before cafe.
The jealousy of the Susan
is the motivation for
prohibitions against certain
intimate contact with non outweigh peoples
because these alliances will end up
entailing recognition of
the gods of these peoples,
the covenant with Yahweh Way.
We'll also,
we shall see soon preclude alliances
with other human competitors.
If Israel serves a divine king,
she can't for example,
serve a human king and that's an idea
that will express itself in Biblical texts
as we see that are clearly opposed to
the creation of a monarchy in Israel.
Not everyone was on board with the idea
that Israel should be ruled by king.
So there are texts that will object
to the creation of the monarchy,
King Saul and King David and so on.
They're also texts that are going to
object to alliances with any foreign king
or subservience to any foreign king,
whether it's Egypt or Syria, or Babylonia.
So subservience to human king,
native or foreign is in these texts
considered a rejection of the divine
kingship,
which is the ideal,
the exclusive kingship of Yahweh and
the scene as a breach of the covenant.
Now,
ancient near eastern suzerainty models
also speak repeatedly of the vassals love
for the service for the Susan,
right?
Vassal So-and-so will love
the Assyrian Lord. So and so.
And that's an element that is not absent
at all in the biblical texts that deal
with the covenant bond the Israelites
promised to serve and to love. Yeah,
halfway.
That's an additional theme that's
associated regularly with the covenant.
It's one that will take
up in greater detail,
though when we get to the
book of Deuteronomy where
it is stressed to a greater
degree than it is in exodus.
But for now,
we can accept Levinson's claim that Sinai
represents an intersection of law and
love because of the use
of the suzerainty model.
So the covenant concept is critical to
the Bible's portrayal and understanding
of the relationship
between God and Israel.
The entire history of Israel as portrayed
by biblical writers is going to be
governed by this one.
Outstanding Reality of covenant Israel.
Fortunes will be seen to ride on the
degree of it's faithfulness to this
covenant.
Exodus closes the book of exodus closes
with the construction of the sanctuary.
Um,
and when the sanctuary is completed,
the tech says the presence of
the Lord filled the tabernacle.
This is a sign of divine approval,
but um,
the long section where we have the receipt
of the instructions for the building
of the temple and then we
have an actual account of,
of those instructions being fulfilled.
And the end, the not sample tabernacle,
excuse me,
it's just a tent structure at this stage.
So receiving the instructions and then
the actual construction of the Tabernacle
that extends from exodus 25 to
the end of the book, exodus 40,
but it's interrupted in exodus 32 by the
account of the Israelites apostasy with
the golden calf. It's just a
great and very ambiguous story.
But the moment of Israel's greatest
glory is to be the moment of her greatest
shame.
As Moses Receives God's
Covenant on Mount Sinai,
he's there at the top of Sinai communing
with God the Israelites who are
encamped at the foot of the mountain,
grow, restless and rebellious.
And they demand of Aaron a God because
they don't know what's become of this
fellow Moses. They said, what
about this? This guy, Moses,
they use a very colloquial
kind of term to dismiss him.
So Aaron feeling the heat makes a golden
calf and the people down bow down to it
and someone declares, this
is your God, o Israel,
who brought you out of the land
of Egypt. Well, and enraged.
God tells Moses,
you know what's going on down there.
And he tells them to descend from
the mountain. The people are sitting,
they've already gone astray, a
stray, and he says, I'm through.
I want to destroy the nation and I'm going
to start a new nation again from you.
Moses. Moses manages to play
Kate God momentarily. Um,
and then he turns around to face the
people. He comes down from the mountain.
He approaches the camp,
you stunned by what he sees.
He's carrying the tablets and all of the
instruction and he smashes them at the
foot of the mountain and fury.
He manages to halt the activities.
He punishes the perpetrators.
He has a few choice words for Erin.
This temporary alienation from God is
ultimately repaired through Moses's
intense prayer and intercession and it
actually takes several chapters to reach
a resolution and God
pelts for quite awhile.
But a renewal of the covenant does occur
and another set of stone tablets is
given,
given and according to one biblical texts,
the broken tablets as well as the, the
new tablets are both placed in the Ark.
Um,
and this is embarrassing.
Episode is just the beginning of a
sequence of embarrassing events that will
occur as the Israelites move from Egypt
towards the land that's been promised to
them.
Most of these episodes will occur in
the book of numbers and they involve the
rebellion of the people in some way.
Generally God's fury in
reaction to that rebellion.
Moses's intervention usually on behalf
of the people and God's appeasement.
So the book of numbers recounts the
itinerary of the Israelites throughout the
40 years of their wanderings and
encampments around the sacred Tabernacle.
The Tabernacle always moves in
the center of the of the tribes,
and they're positioned in certain specific
positions around the tabernacle as
they, as they move. They
stay at Sinai for a year,
I believe in the text before they begin.
Their movement and numbers contains
some law and much narrative material.
The material tells of God's provision
for the people in the desert,
but it also tells the Israelites
constant complaining and rebellion.
The Israelites rebelled against Moses
and God and they long for Egypt.
There are several times when God
threatens to exterminate them,
but Moses manages to dissuade in
numbers 14 for example, the Israelites.
When the Israelites Complain Again,
God is determined to destroy them and
Moses intervenes and the intervention
leads to a compromise.
God swears that none of the
adults who witnessed the exodus,
with the exception of Joshua and Caleb,
who did not join in the rebellion,
but none of the adults who witnessed
the exodus would see the fulfillment of
God's salvation and
enter the promised land.
This means the Israelites will have to
wander for 40 years in the desert until
all of those who left
Egypt as adults pass away,
leaving a new generation that
hasn't really tasted slavery, uh,
to enter the land and form a new nation.
The book of numbers I think is most
remarkable for the relationship that it
describes between Moses and God.
I love reading these particular stories
and just hearing the dialogue between
them and imagining it because the two of
them alternate in losing patients with
the Israelites and wishing
to throw them over. Um,
but each time the one convinces the
other to be forbearing the relationship
between Moses and God
is a very intimate one.
Very much like a husband and wife are
sort of working as together as partners in
parenting a difficult child.
Um,
but they're trying to prepare their
partners in the preparation of Israel for
their new life readying Israel for life
in God's land as a nation, as a people.
I'm going to just give you two examples
of the way Moses and God act as a check
upon each other.
The first excerpt is from numbers 14 and
it shows Moses his ability to placate
the wrath of God. Now in this
story, the Israelites, um,
express great fear. They've just heard
a report from a reconnaissance team, um,
that scoped out the land and they
come back and say, oh boy, you know,
it looks really bad.
And then they think that the chances of
conquering the promised land are very,
very slim.
The whole community broken to loud
cries and the people wept that night.
All the Israelites railed
against Moses and Aaron.
If only we had died in the land of Egypt,
the whole community shouted at them.
Or if only we might
die in this wilderness,
why has the Lord taking us to
that land to fall by the sword?
Our wives and children
will be carried off.
It would be better for us to go back
to Egypt and they said to one another,
let's head back for Egypt.
The presence of the Lord appeared in the
tent of meeting to all the Israelites,
and the Lord said to Moses,
how long would this people spurned me?
How long will they have no faith in me?
Despite all the signs that
I've performed in their midst,
I will strike them with pestilence and
disown them and I will make of you a
nation far more numerous than they.
But Moses said to the Lord,
and when the Egyptians from
WHO's midst you brought up this,
people in your might hear the news,
they will tell it to the
inhabitants of that land.
If then you slay this people to a man,
the nations who have heard
your fame will say, oh,
it must be because the lord was powerless
to bring the people into the land.
He had promised them on oath that he
slaughtered them in the wilderness.
Therefore, I pray, let my lords for
Barron's be a bounding and kindness,
forgiving iniquity and transgression.
Pardon?
I pray the iniquity of this
people according to your
great kindness as you have
forgiven these people ever since Egypt.
And the Lord said,
I pardon as you have asked.
So nope.
God's offer to start all over again
with Moses. This is that. This is a,
this is a pattern with this God,
you know,
create good subset of
flood wipes them out.
Let's start again and it's still not too
good. Let's choose one person, Abraham,
see how that goes up?
Disappointed. Let's go with Moses.
So this is a bit of a pattern,
but Moses refuses to accept the offer
and instead he defends the Israelites and
he averts their destruction.
He appeals primarily to God's vanity.
What will the neighbors think?
If you destroy them,
they'll think you couldn't
fulfill your promise.
They'll think you're not the
universal God of history.
But the roles are reversed
in the following passage.
And this is where, you know,
the text is blows hot and cold. In fact,
that's there's a rabbinic image that, um,
there's a rabbinic tradition that talks
about this period of time and has gotten
most of talking. And God
says, listen, between the two
of us, whenever I blow hot,
you blow cold. Or when you, when
I pour hot water, you pour cold.
And when you pour hot, I'll
pour cold. And you know,
together we'll muddle through and get
through here and the Israelites won't be
wiped out. But in this next
passage, which is a numbers 11,
Moses is the one who's
impatient with the Israelites,
constant complaints and lack of faith.
And he's ready to throw in the towel.
I'll just read this last passage.
The riff Raff in their midst
felt a gluttonous craving.
And then the Israelites wept and
said, Oh, if only we had meat to eat.
We remembered the fish that we used to
eat free in Egypt. Okay, we were slaves,
but the food was free. You know,
as there's love that line we use,
eat this fish free in Egypt,
the cucumbers, the melons,
the Leeks, the onions,
and the garlic. Now our gullets are
shriveled. There's nothing at all.
Nothing but this manner to look at.
Moses heard the people weeping,
every clan apart,
each person at the entrance of his tent
and the Lord was very angry and Moses
was distressed and Moses said to the Lord,
why have you dealt with your servant?
Me? Why have I not enjoyed your favor
that you have laid the burden of all this
people on me?
Did I conceived all this people?
Did I bear them that you should say to me,
carry them in your bosom as
a nurse carries an infant
to the land that you have
promised on oath to their fathers.
Where am I to get meat to give to all
this people when they wind before me and
say, give us meat to eat. I cannot
carry all this people by myself.
It's too much for me.
If you would deal thus with me,
kill me rather I beg you and let me see.
No more of my wretchedness.
And the Lord said to Moses,
gather for me,
70 of Israel's elders of whom you have
experienced as elders and officers of the
people,
and bring them to the tent of meeting
and let them take their place there with
you.
And I will come down and speak with you
there and I will draw upon the spirit
that is on you and put it upon them
and they shall share the burden of the
people with you and you shall not
bear it alone. So again, hot and cold.
And in many ways, Moses sets the
paradigm for the classical prophet.
He performs this double duty.
He chastises and upgrades the Israelites
for their rebellion and failures,
right when he's turning and facing
the people he's, he's on their case.
But at the same time he consoles the
people when they fear they've driven God
away irreparably.
And when he turns to face God,
he defends the people before God.
He pleads for mercy when they do in fact
deserve punishment and he knows they
deserve punishment. He even says as
much, but please have mercy at times.
He expresses his frustration with the
difficulty of his task and resentment that
it's been assigned to him,
but we'll consider the character and
the role of Moses in much greater detail
when we reached the book of Deuteronomy.
Uh,
next Monday for the coming week,
I would like you to please
pay particular attention.
We're dealing with two topics that will
be, I think perhaps for some of you,
a little different.
New Alien.
We're going to be dealing with biblical
law on Monday and biblical ritual,
purity tech's holiness
temple on Wednesday.
These are worlds apart from many
of the things we know. So please,
there's a lot of of textual reading
to do for Monday and Wednesday.
Please do it carefully and I might even
hand out a little bit of a study guide
to help you with that.